well i know a lot of you have been
worrying about
uh self-defense which i think is is
really important you know
um i want to teach you something uh this
gentleman here uh he's a
captain frank hox he's gonna teach you
about the captain of
i have no idea uh but he's going to
teach you about the warriors ritual
it's not wharf we don't want to if you
look right away you're going to start
with this
warrior ritual and you're calling
yourself captain i have a right to know
what you're a captain
of because you could be a captain on a
commercial fishing ship
which is nothing maybe he's a cruise
ship captain that's even less than
a fair enough let's see
the good ship lollipop made me
whoa dude
yeah okay dude i've had screensavers
before i know
[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls my name is what this is the guy
this is a captain that was a weird
transition it's a guy this is the guy
also how small is that room it's very
tiny
it's a closet captain frank hawks and we
are beginning
a new series of videos about
really dry lips about lips that are
really
really dry they're chapping
and then i pick them with my teeth
it's all you can see now right and it's
making me uh
and then i pick at my dry lips it's like
when people don't clear their throat
it's the same thing that's making me now
i gotta clean my throat and my lips
this guy's a mess on the subject matter
and i am shaking the camera pretty
pretty well
on the subject matter of he looks like
unemployment the person yeah
you don't want to [ __ ] with him training
he looks like the kind of guy that's
like
unemployed and then he's like he'll like
say like yeah i was um
you know whatever like i was like oh i
went i put in two applications today
um it's just
he's the one that yeah he he goes he
applies for a job he knows he's not
going to get so you keep getting
unemployment when he calls you
unemployment office
training uh weapons training
specifically um we're going to do a
variation for sword and we're going to
do a variation
for tomahawk and long knife on the bases
because they tell you if you're gonna
have self-defense
you won't always have a gun and a
tomahawk on you
tomahawk listen if i have a gun on me
and you
a managed to get away from me or b i
unload the whole thing and i don't hit
you once
i shouldn't deserve to have a tomahawk
back up like at that point you should
just win
you should beat me to death with the gun
and then tatanka is going to sue you so
that's going to be a whole thing
i think he's going to make a terrible
cameo video yeah reasonable than that
so let's see some of these moves in
action um
see you in the rest of the video okay
first of all the [ __ ] nerve of this
guy to have one of those things on his
desk that has like the in and out
paperwork
you know like oh this is my incoming and
this is my outgoing how dare you sir
do you want to see some sick moves okay
so if you hear any noise in the
background i apologize
i live in a trailer park so we're
beginning the warriors ritual
that is a trailer this video oh yeah of
course it's pretty it's
a prefab homes because you can look
across the street and it's the same like
look at how close that other house is
is going to be mostly the beginning and
the end
and not a lot of middle um
please understand that i'm still wore
out i did wait a day
before i started this entire process
the ritual is the putting together
and the taking down of the
ropes on the pel the pel is permanently
cemented in a
bucket home depot bucket
the reason why i did not post it in the
ground is because
first of all the hoa has rules yeah and
i pay lot rent
actually so i like okay so
so the trailer is mine but then i gotta
put i don't own the lit
trying to explain it all that would
require permission from
where i live i was kidding
i mean we knew the reason yeah you know
to say it i'm not going to do that
i'm not going to wait on permission for
anybody also but
i'm not going to wait on permission for
anybody but he still didn't do it
also uh you live in a trailer park so
when you go like
uh also i'd have to ask for permission
from my landlord
and like okay then ask the reason they
didn't is
what he wanted to say was uh it is not
uh permanently put in the ground because
uh you need to get permission
and i'm also late on my rent because you
know that's what it is
that's what it is because it's like
nobody in my apartment complex
listens to any rules there's a couple of
people that do follow the rules
those are the people that are always
behind on their rent and they're like
hey let's
let's try to be good neighbors right oh
you didn't pay your rent did you
everyone else is just people selling
weed people blasting music at two in the
morning it's like
whatever i pay my rent get out of here
and
second of all i wanted something that i
could knock down that wood move that
would react to what i do
or you cement it in a bucket
and i actually ended up having a
neighbor's friend to do that
so like captain hawks here didn't do it
himself
yeah hey what happened to why don't you
subscribe to the warrior spirit
and do it yourself you couldn't put a
pole into a bucket full of cement
why don't you subscribe to do it
yourself videos yeah
the purpose behind the ropes is first of
all that is
that's all i could find in the bed of my
work truck half inch
manila rope it's not light it's not
heavy
but it's not light and it it is
part of the workout oh this is the
workout
of the pelvis this is called ring around
the rosie is part
of the workout all right when is justin
hawk bradshaw going to be done pulling
his bull rope up on the [ __ ]
turnbuckle
i'm going to i'm going to skip ahead
from the rope thing it's a lot of rope
it's a lot of rope as you can see
all right here we go now we got it now
we're set so you have to set the rope
and here we go
i'm going to skip the second part of
anatomy on this
now jacob scott shows that this is just
light cardio not even really
you're right it's just a nice day
outside doing a small project yeah
and i i probably just said this it's a
lot like
uh shooting at a paper target it's just
like it's not
gonna happen you're never to be like wow
this looks really good there's not
enough tinfoil
can i put some i can't go out in the sun
though he's there with a black umbrella
like wednesday adams
one of those like little tents yeah like
the ones that just go up and around
and they're like one of those little pop
tents to go yeah exactly you're talking
about
if like a person's going to move it's
not going to think
here we go but this is the anatomy here
we go you're right
groin perfect here we go you ready
let's see hydration he needs to hydrate
gotta have some of that baja blast
whatever the [ __ ] he's drinking
it's not even that you know how like
walmart has the generic powdered sports
drink that you mixed
that's what that is it's the blue that
blue flavor the thing that literally
tastes like blue
i don't know how but it just tastes like
blue
here we go get ready folks hey i wanna
just say before we do this if you have
any kids watching the show now we'll be
at time to game in a different room
because this is
this is brutal here's what i don't get
like can't you just get a light like you
live in a trailer park you couldn't
you don't know how to make math you
couldn't find any kids
like normal people come on like normal
people doing a trailer work
[Laughter]
here we go oh he's dual wielding
setting up range
that wouldn't be very effective like i'm
just saying if you did that to me
sir it would hurt
but it would be it would be one of those
where you go ow
it's vicious what are you doing this is
vicious
that is a traditional nickel more
uh well macklemore
uh drill setup us
i don't know why h john benjamin's
brother's doing this but it's making me
feel awkward
dude i honestly like this is giving me
flashbacks to
when i had to do master pose tv show
pilot
and he was doing the knife fighting guys
and it was just
and yeah look at that that way look how
sick that is see fit
um or you could yeah there's
the micklemore punches and all of it's
not that's not doing anything
dude this is pretty cool you know what
it is is that mike isn't it
look and i get it mike i don't really
even blame you you're not a skilled
warrior
anybody right i don't know much about
the art of the blade yeah you don't
you don't know any you don't know really
anything about this and that's fine you
know you're not
but uh what if i'm gonna help him out
here i'm gonna help i'm waiting i'm
waiting to hear somebody walk in the
frame and go
hey bear you seen the rope from my boat
i ain't seen it nowhere man it looked
like i went missing the cops have
definitely been to this guy's trailer
before
many times many times like hey man your
neighbors called again
and are you out there doing like knife
and axe
are you simulating a and a murderer in
your hand
look the neighbors have said they it
looks like you are pretending to rip
and murder a metal pole covered in rope
in your backyard is this true
and they walk out they go frank listen
it's captain frank all right let captain
frank listen look
we're getting complaints again okay you
live across the street from the plate
from the playground
kids are getting scared can you please
stop your karate fights
i mean you think a [ __ ] uh uh i mean
this guy definitely is old school
warrior style though he's currently like
one of those um you know guys that likes
the
doesn't like to use too much technology
i mean look at his non-motorized uh
lawnmower
behind him the manual manual what is
that
lawnmower behind him oh no which is you
want to talk about
peak poor people yeah that's terrible
because
it's it's one of those items where the
non-motorized
lawnmower not that that's like look i'm
all for if you have a small yard and
you're like i'm not buying a [ __ ]
lawnmower that costs money or whatever
but like
to get the cheapest gas powered lawn
mower
isn't that much more expensive than the
non-motorized lawnmower like it's not a
steep discount
so it's just like that's when you know
somebody's super poor and they spend all
their money on math when they're like
well i don't know honey because it's
it's 65
for the lawnmower without the power
without the gas power
but the gas powered one's like 85 so we
gotta
like just get the regular one
i call that letting him fall
and i want to apologize because i made a
mistake i said it was a home depot
bucket
i am now learning that it's a lowe's
bucket okay it is that's right
i apologize
i love the people having a little
conversation you can hear it over
over here in the back goal what the [ __ ]
dude
ah i missed breaking the rope that would
work a lot better if it was in the
ground and not in a bucket that could
fall over
it would also work a lot better if
he was doing anything at all but he's
not doing any like
he's not even doing any cool moves or
anything no
so what's he doing right now what he's
doing is having the video load
i i can't i we've been cut off by the
dipstick you're gonna encounter your own
frustration
and there i'm i'm working up the
chambers
and just all right so like i'm sure
you've seen
it why are more forced to open up a
pistachio shell
i'm sure you think i'm sure you've seen
videos of
real actual martial artists that like
are really do really cool with swords
like i'm seeing them like you know
a lot of the people that do like the
hollywood fight scenes are actually real
like martial arts guys and whatever
his form look i'm obviously i'm not a
martial arts guy
his form is so terrible he's just like
yeah he's just tapping on on a pull like
it's not like like i would understand if
you're doing like real martial arts
stuff they will do it slowly and
delicately because they're not trying to
actually stab things but like
they actually look cool this guy doesn't
look cool doing anything he's just
he looks like he's doing what you see
like
uh like a really poor
nine or ten year old kid doing you ever
see like a 10 year old poor kid
in a trailer park like they're the kind
of kids that would be like i'm going to
tie this rope to this pool
and then i'm going to do karate moves to
it but it's like it's like when you see
that like kid growing up that had no dad
and they didn't learn anything but so
they're
they're trying to wing it and do
everything on their own and it just
looks terrible
this guy just stinks oh yeah that's a
good point want to know says well he's
formless meaning you cannot comprehend
his form
you know who he was trained by right vox
day
oh [ __ ] dude yeah so now you want put
some respect on his name please
he's lightly tapping he's missing half
the time working my ranges
he's working his right now i'm going to
do really up close tomahawk long night
fighting
you showed that pole
and the thing is like isn't the point of
this right like let's say you got this
rope wrapped around a pole right mm-hmm
and let's say you weren't a [ __ ] you
actually cemented it into the ground
because you actually paid your rent
see again if you'd paid your rent sir
and the landlord came and went you can't
just be burying a [ __ ] thing and
you go it's literally a hole in the
ground the size of a lowe's bucket i'll
fill
in when i move out i've paid my rent get
the [ __ ] out of here get the [ __ ] out of
here and they leave
if you've paid your rent on time they're
like they don't really fight you about
this [ __ ]
but if you're dug into the ground and
you had this thing set up
why wouldn't you hit it why wouldn't you
really like
go at it yeah is it the whole point like
of a boxing like
for instance when you when you go to a
boxing gym or you have a punching bag
but like the whole i know some people
use it as a workout but
the point of a punching bag the original
point is to practice your punches
so that you can punch once punch like
you go okay that one was weak okay that
one i didn't stiffen up the arm enough
like the whole point of a punching bag
is to practice getting good at punching
and this
[ __ ] dude just isn't even putting any
force into it uh chris radzino says uh
he couldn't have been trained by uh by
fox day sorry
he's a point warrior oh that's true he's
a point warrior this isn't a this isn't
a real warrior
so filipino shea is asking nicely said
royce could you just play this at normal
speed clearly this guy is blindingly
fast oh
you know what the problem you were
playing it i'm going to slow it down
please you're right you're right i'm
going to slow it down for you everybody
there we go okay you're surviving
actually maybe
let's see how this looks and
uh that kid
by the way you know what else is great
about how bad his form is
let's say i'm in my house right and i
can't get to a gun or something
and there's like an axe next to me and
somebody breaks in right
he's doing that thing where he's he
keeps leading he keeps
winding up he's like yeah yeah it's like
you're gonna
literally he's going to block that [ __ ]
he's literally going
and you're going that's you'd be dead
you would be dead
just or
a variety of things this is what he
really sounds like
um including
defending your life
you know what would probably like this
really great albert brooks film
if you know what would happen if this
guy was coming at you and i have a real
good way to stop him so this is coming
at you know what i would do
shoot him with a gun that's a good one
you know what i would do
call the police he lives in a trailer
park he clearly has warrants
i bet you has warrants he doesn't even
know about he's that guy
this is the guy that's been at a bar
before and he wasn't even in the fight
yep but the cops start running names and
they're like you come with us and he's
like oh come on man i paid that ticket
and you know what it is this guy has a
warrant out for his arrest right now and
it's
you know what it is it's for like
illegal dumping
it's it you know what i mean it's it's
not even like a oh did he rob somebody
or like diddle a kid
no he's one of those guys that probably
got caught he kept dumping old washing
machines and dryers in the same public
park area
and the cops kept telling him look man
we're gonna charge you he probably has a
warrant out for felony dumping improper
dumping
uh and it's really hard to get a felony
dumping it has to be like a tires and a
refrigerator
it has to be either really bad for the
environment or i've seen it in tampa too
where you
just keep doing it yeah and then because
i've seen some guys get felony because
they own
like a junk removal service and they've
been caught so many times doing it that
they're like we have to make a felony
now like
you're clearly not getting the message